[Music]
I'm gonna throw out a name and I just
want to know your thoughts on this
person okay
Denise Richard I love Denise Richards
wouldn't it be so cool to see Denise
Richards as a housewife I think she
would be a sensational housewife in
Beverly Hills I do too yeah if some
announcement were to be made when might
we expect an announcement like that the
thing about it is we don't announce
casting until the show is really about
to come out so so you're not gonna hear
anything from me for a while from west
coast to East Coast Andy Cohen is
spilling the housewives tea with et talk
to me about the Real Housewives of New
York reunion what can fans expect you
know what I watched part one on the
plane today and it's great
LuAnn is not there as you know what's
interesting is the women are gunning for
Bethenny yeah oh yeah big time they came
ready to to go with her yeah
many of us now have been in situations
were Bethenny where maybe she hasn't
been so kind so we're less tolerant to
being compassionate
you know Luann's not there how will she
be represented we discuss everything
that happened with LuAnn this season and
there's a lot of new information filling
in a lot of blanks that all the other
women they all shed a lot of new light
so we do advance the story you will be
happy to know Carole who's one of my
favorite housewives is not going to be
returning next year
could we expect to see a fresh face or a
familiar face fill that role the great
thing about New York is the history so
we love people who have history with the
group and there can be people you know
Dorinda had history with the group but
you had never really seen her before
Jill Zarin has a lot of history with the
group she sure does yeah she sure does
of course it's more than the housewives
keeping Andy busy he's also hosting love
connection on Fox the classic show
back and it's hotter wilder and more
shocking ever
you yourself are hosting a reboot love
connection do you have any TV shows that
you would love to see get revived or
rebooted playboy after dark which my
show is modeled after you know the
Grateful Dead spiked the punch on
playboy after dark with LSD in the day
and that's the kind of show that needs
to be on TV you know a pretty wild on
your show they do I know but we haven't
we haven't we haven't explored LSD live
on in late night hey sweeps
could be
[Music]